the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hi last time I left you dangling and
suspense when I said what happens if the
terms in a series are not all positive
in other words the trouble with the last
assignment was is that we did quite a
bit of work and yet there was a very
stringent condition namely at every term
that you were adding happened to be a
positive number now obviously this need
not be the case and the question is can
you have convergence in a series in
which the terms are not all positive and
what does it mean by the way if this is
the case why we stressed the situation
of positive series and this will be the
aim of today's lecture to straighten out
both of these points any rate I call
today's less than absolute convergence
and I hope that the meaning of this will
become clear very soon as we go along
but to answer the first question that we
brought up let's take a series in which
the terms are not all positive now by
the way I will do more general things in
our supplementary notes on this material
I felt though that for a blackboard
illustration I should pick a relatively
straightforward example and not try to
generalize it let's take the specific
series 1 minus 1/2 plus 1/3 minus of
minus 1/4 plus 1/5 etc and how do we
indicate the end trim in this case
notice that the denominator is n the
numerator oscillates between minus 1 and
1 and you see the mathematical trick two
alternate signs is to raise minus one to
a power you see minus one to an even
power will be part positive one and to
an odd power negative one the idea is
since for N equals one we want this to
be positive we tacked on the plus one
here you see in that case and being one
n plus 1 is 2 minus 1 squared is 1 and
at any rate don't be confused by this
notation it's simply a cute way of
alternating signs at any rate what do we
have in this particular series we have
that the terms alternate in sign ok we
also have that the nth term approaches
zero namely the numerator alternates
between plus and minus 1 the denominator
is
so as n increases the terms converge on
zero as a limit and finally the terms
keep decreasing monotonically in
magnitude in other words forgetting
about the fact that the plus outranks a
minus in terms of a number line notice
that the size of one third is less than
the size of one half in other words this
particular series which is called an
alternating series has three properties
it's called alternating because the
terms alternate inside the nth term
approaches zero by the way we saw in our
first lecture on series that the nth
term approaching zero was necessary but
not sufficient for making a series
converge however what I claim is that if
in addition to this we know that the
terms decrease in magnitude our claim is
that the given series will converge in
other words what I intend to show is
that 1 minus 1/2 plus 1/3 etc does
converge and the way I'm going to do
that is geometrically I'm not going to
try to prove this thing analytically but
as I've said before the analytic proof
virtually is just an abstraction of what
we're doing over here let's take a look
and see what happens over here so you
notice that our first term is 1 ok our
next term is 1/2 our next term is 1
minus 1/2 plus 1/3 which is 5/6 what I'm
driving at is that if you compute the
sums 1 minus 1/2 plus 1/3 minus 1/4 etc
in the order in which they're given what
you find is that the sequence of partial
sums is 1 1/2 5 6 7 12:47 sixtieths 13
twentieths now the thing that I want you
to see the reason I'm waving my hand
here and why I think this helps in the
lecture is look what's happening you see
because the terms alternate in sign what
this means is that as I start with S sub
1 over here the next term will be to the
left of S sub 1 then the term after that
will be to the right then to the left
then to the right then to the left then
to the right they keep alternating the
way more over since the the terms
decrease in magnitude it means that each
jump is less than the jump that came
immediately before in other words as I
jump from here to here when I jump back
I don't come back quite as far in other
words what I'm doing now is is I'm
closing in you see the odd subscripts
and the even subscripts are sort of
segregated you see what's happening over
here and finally because the limit of
the enter the nth term is zero it means
that this spacing see the difference
between successive partial sums is the
nth term that must go to zero in other
words our limit L is in here and as n
increases the squeezes put on and we get
the existence of a limit for example
whatever L is it must be between
thirteen twentieths and forty-seven
sixtieths by the way I say this in the
form of an aside it turns out and for
those of us who haven't seen this before
it's a very mystic result that's why I
say who'd have guessed it it turns out
that L is actually the natural log of
two and the reason I point this out is
that again you may have you may recall
it in our notes we talked about Cauchy
convergence meaning what do you do when
you don't know how to guess the limit
you see the idea is notice that this
particular series converges but we don't
know what the limit is other than the
fact that it's being squeezed in over
here you see here's a case where we know
the limit exists but it's particularly
difficult to explicitly name what that
limit is but that fact notwithstanding
is it clear that because of the fact
that the terms alternate the magnitudes
decrease and the limit is zero that
these things do converge to a limit and
I think it is clear but the next
question and I apologize for what looks
like slang here but I think this is
exactly what's going on in your minds
right now so what what does this have to
do with what came before and what will
come later
and we're going to see again a very very
strange thing that happens with infinite
sums that does not happen with finite
sums let me lead into that fairly
gradually
see first of all I claim that this
particular series seen again don't get
misled by this is just a fancy way of
saying what 1 minus 1/2 plus 1/3 etc
converges but because the plus terms
cancel the minus terms the pluses cancel
the minuses not because the terms get
small fast enough what I mean that that
is this forget about the signs in here
replace each term by its magnitude and
by the way that's where the name
absolute convergence is going to come
from namely the magnitude of a term is
its absolute value you see and this is
what we're going to be talking about but
the idea is this if we replace each term
by its magnitude we obtain the series
summation n goes from 1 to infinity 1
over N and in the last assignment we saw
in the in the exercises that this
diverged by the integral test in other
words if we leave out the signs the
series diverges because evidently these
terms don't get small fast enough ok let
me stay the definition the definition is
simply this the series summation n goes
from 1 to infinity a sub n is said to
converge absolutely if the series that
you get by replacing each term by its
magnitude converges ok now I leave for
the supplementary notes the proof that
if a series converges absolutely it
converges in the first place in other
words I think it's rather clear if you
look at this thing intuitively that if I
replace each term by its magnitude I
disregard the plus and minus signs and
that resulting series converges then the
original series must have converged also
because the terms couldn't be any bigger
than this by the way the form of proof
is kind of messy in places and so this
is why as I say I leave this for the
supplementary notes ok but any rate
that's what we mean by absolute
convergence if you're given a series you
replace each term by its magnitude if
that series converges we call the
original series absolutely convergent
notice by the way the tie in now between
absolute can
and positive series namely by definition
the absolute value of a sub n is at
least as big as 0 consequently when
we're testing for absolute convergence
the series that we test is positive and
we have you see tests for convergence
for positive series now the sequel to
definition one is of course definition
two and that says what a series which
converges but not absolutely is called
conditionally convergent in other words
it converges on the condition that the
signs stay exactly the way they are an
example of a conditionally convergent
series is the one that we're dealing
with right now namely with the pluses
and minuses in there we just show that
the series converges however if we
replace each term by its magnitude the
resulting series of summation 1 over N
and that is we saw diverges
okay now the question is what's so bad
about conditional convergence or what
difference does it make whether a series
converges absolutely or conditionally is
there any problem that comes up there's
as I said before a fantastic subtlety
that occurs a subtlety that has no
parallel in our knowledge of finite
arithmetic and the subtlety is this in
fact I call it that the subtlety of
conditional convergence namely the sum
are they conditionally convergent series
and this is fantastic
depends on the order in which you write
the terms in other words if the series
converges but conditionally if you
change the order of the terms surprising
as it may seem you actually change the
sum and the best way to do this I think
at this stage a generalization is given
the supplementary notes but the idea is
let me just do this in terms of the
problem that we were dealing with let's
take the terms of our conditionally
convergent series 1 minus 1/2 plus 1/3
etc and divide them into two teams and
if this expression bothers you call the
teams sets and that makes it much more
mathematical let the first set consist
of the positive terms of a series namely
1 1/3 1/5 and in general 1 over 2 n
minus 1
where n is any positive whole number the
negative members of our team - a half
are the set N which I'll call the
negative members as minus 1/2 minus 1/4
minus 1/6 in general - 1 over 2n now
again by the integral test we saw in our
last lesson that both these series
summation 1 over 2n minus 1 and
summation 1 over 2n diverge to infinity
by the integral test now what my claim
is is that because both of these two
series diverged I can now rearrange my
terms to get any sum that I want well
for example suppose somebody says to me
make the sum come out to be 3 halves
right
as I mentioned later there's nothing
sacred about 3 halves in fact I'm
mentioning that now but I'll say it
again later for emphasis I just wanted
to pick a number that wouldn't be too
unwieldy but here's what the gist is I
want to make this sum at least 3 halves
so what I do is I start with my positive
terms from the set P and add them up 1
plus 1/3 plus 1/5 etc the thing that I'm
sure of
is that eventually this sum must exceed
3 halves why do I know that well P
diverges to infinity how could people
diverge to infinity if it could if the
sum could never the sum of the terms in
P diverges to infinity how could that
happen if the sum never got at least as
big as 3 halves
so the idea is I write down all these
terms add them up until my sum first
exceeds or equals 3 halves as I say this
must happen because the series diverges
to infinity well in particular I observe
that 1 plus 1/3 plus 1/5 is 23 15 and
that's now for the first time bigger
than 3 halves well I do next is I
annexed the negative members in that in
other words the members of capital n
until the sum falls below 3 halves see
watch what I'm doing here
see I stopped that 150 I have one plus
1/3 plus 1/5 now I subtract 1/2
that gives me 31 30th and that's less
than 3 halves so now my son is below 3
halves what I do next is I continue with
P where I left off see I left off with
1/5 I now start tacking on one seventh
one nine one eleventh one 13th etc until
the sum again exceeds three halves now
how do I know the sum has to exceed
three halves well remember when we add
up all the members of P we get a
divergent series that means that some
gets increases without bound as we've
mentioned many times so far in our
course that if you chop off a finite
number of terms from a divergent series
the remaining series what's left
still must diverge in other words if
this series 1 plus 1/3 plus 1/5 plus 1/7
diverges to infinity the fact that I
chopped off those terms that add up to
adjust an excess of 3 halves
what's left they're still going to
diverge to infinity so I can keep on
going this way you see what I do is I
add on 1/7 the result turns out to be
247 over 210 which is still less than
three halves and to spare you the gory
details and believe me they are gory I
worked it out myself with other without
a desk calculator this gets to be a mess
it turns out that when I add on one 13th
get down to here the sum is this which
is still less than three halves but then
I add on 115th the sum gets to be this
which I simply call K that turns out to
be greater than three halves then you
see what I do is return to my series of
negative terms tack those on until the
Sun falls below and what's happening
here pictorially is the following you
see what happened was three halves I add
on terms till I exceeded three halves
that was 23 15 then I get down below
three halves then up again above three
halves and still sparing you the details
notice what's happening each time that I
pass three halves I pass it by less than
before because the
terms are getting smaller in magnitude
what's happening is and I hope this
crazy little diagram here serves the
purpose you see what's happening is I'm
zeroing in on three halves in other
words this particular rearrangement will
guarantee me that those terms will add
up to three halves now again it says as
I said before three halves was not
important though the arithmetic gets
Messier and again that's the best word I
can think of in other words I went
through several sheets of paper just
trying to get to the next stage over
here before I realized it wasn't worth
it I mean it's something that you can
all do on our own but the larger number
that you choose the more terms you're
going to have to add up before you
exceed this you see don't confuse two
things here I obviously have to add up
an awful lot of terms of the form one a
third a fifth seventh and ninth and
eleventh to get say a million but the
point is that since that series diverges
eventually by going out far enough now
far enough might be billions of terms
but still a finite number the sum will
exceed 1 million so that's the key point
in other words I can keep oscillating
around any sum that I want just by
exceeding it coming back with the
negative terms getting less than that
and alternating back and forth again
this will be left for much greater
detail for the supplementary notes and
the exercises you see now I mentioned a
little bit more about that in a few
minutes but the summary so far is this
if the series summation n goes from 1 to
infinity a sub n is conditionally
convergent its limit exists let's not
forget that its limit exists but that
limit depends are not changing the order
in which the terms were given in other
words the limit changes as the order of
the terms has changed that is
rearranging the terms actually changes a
series and there is nothing in finite
arithmetic that is comparable to this in
other words if you have 50 numbers to
add up or 50 million numbers or 50
billion numbers no matter how you
rearrange those numbers the sum exists
and is the same independently of what
the rearrangement is you see this is not
comparable to find-out arithmetic
and the moral is and again I say this in
slang expression because I want this to
rub off I want you to remember this
don't monkey with conditional
convergence if the series is
conditionally convergent make sure that
you add the terms in the order in which
they appear that if you change the order
you will get a different limit and what
will happen is you will get a limit that
is the right answer to the wrong problem
in other words changing the order of the
terms changes the limit and this is why
conditional convergence is particularly
annoying it means that all these things
that come natural and ordinary
arithmetic are lacking in conditional
convergence now what is the sequel to
this the sequel is is that all as well
when you have absolute convergence in
other words that I just wrote this out
to make sure that we have this in front
of us the beauty of absolute convergence
is that the sum of an absolutely
convergent series is the same for every
rearrangement of the terms the details
are left to the supplementary notes now
what am I trying to bring out by all of
this you see the beauty of positive
series is that every time we talk about
absolute convergence the test involves a
positive series in other words by
knowing how to test positive series for
convergence we can test any series for
absolute convergence what is the beauty
of absolute convergence the beauty of
absolute convergence is that we can
rearrange the terms in any order that we
want if it's convenient to pick a
different order than another and the sum
will not depend on this rearrangement
you see the point is we are not saying
keep away from conditionally convergent
series in many important applications
you have to come to grips with
conditional convergence all we are
saying is that if you want to be able to
fool around numerically with these
series if you don't have absolute
convergence you're in a bit of trouble
now you see the point is that our
textbook does a very good job in talking
about absolute convergence versus
conditional convergence but for some
reason does not mention the problem of
rearranging terms and therefore much of
what I've talked about today the
importance of that
convergence is in terms of
rearrangements and because this material
is not in the textbook what I have
elected to do is to put this all of this
material that we've talked about today
almost verbatim except in a more
generalized form into the supplementary
notes supplying whatever proofs are
necessary and whatever intuitive ideas
are necessary
at any rate read the supplementary notes
do the exercises and we'll continue our
discussion next time and until next time
goodbye funding for the publication of
this video was provided by the Gabriella
and Paul Rosenbaum foundation
help ocw continue to provide free and
open access to MIT courses by making a
donation at ocw.mit.edu/donate